i had so much fun hanging out with chip
and joanna gaines in waco texas there
were so many hilarious moments i mean we
really did we laughed so much and then
we ended up like making a bloopers reel
joanna was reading the teleprompter and
she kept getting thrown off and chip and
i were on either side of her well you
know what just take a look
i love a good scam yeah love picking it
too
she hosts handcrafted home projects
you can find him he hosts i'm just
kidding he couldn't find it you can say
this part no i can't if you have a real
sweet tooth we have you covered if you
have a sweet toast we got your cup of
toots
i love it chip and joanna if we want
again i'm sorry i was talking to you oh
and i like liked that yes
i gotta have more zoey what does that
mean watch this do i say watch this and
watch this i don't know how to do it you
say it well just say it in a normal way
that makes people want to watch it you
have got to watch this you got to watch
this you got to watch
who is it watch it watch this okay
that's perfect now that's the kind of
promo i'm looking for
we're the worst no way most of that is
gonna work
[Music]